no es un secreto que el agua es esencial
para la vida la mayor parte si no es que
todos los procesos biológicos más
importantes de nuestro cuerpo dependen
del agua y probablemente ocurren dentro
del agua cuando pensamos en las células
de nuestro cuerpo el citoplasma que
tenemos dentro de nuestras células es
principalmente agua incluso yo que ahora
les hablo soy un 60 a 70 por ciento de
agua imaginen me como una gran bolsa de
agua haciendo un vídeo pero no solo los
seres humanos necesitamos agua la vida
que conocemos depende del agua por eso
es que cuando buscamos por signos de
vida en otros planetas lo primero que se
busca es el agua
tal vez la vida también puede ocurrir en
otro tipo de sustancias pero el agua es
esencial para la vida que nosotros
conocemos pero para saber por qué el
agua está en especial empecemos por
entender la estructura del agua y cómo
interactúa consigo misma como ya saben
el agua consiste en
un átomo de oxígeno y dos átomos de
hidrógeno por eso se le llama h2o y
están unidos con enlaces covalentes cada
uno de estos enlaces es un par de
electrones que estos dos átomos simulan
tener y tal vez se pregunten por qué
dibujamos los hidrógenos así porque no
los dibujamos de otra forma bueno eso es
porque el oxígeno también tiene dos
pares de electrones libres entonces como
los electrones se repelen entre sí en
realidad si vemos esto en tres
dimensiones la molécula de oxígeno tiene
una forma de traer y acá voy a dibujarlo
este es el oxígeno después tenemos un
par de electrones libres por aquí otro
par de electrones libres por acá y
después tenemos el enlace covalente con
un átomo de hidrógeno
este es un átomo de hidrógeno y después
tenemos un enlace covalente con el otro
hidrógeno y miren
todo esto se parece a un tetraedro
observen que los hidrógenos están al
final de la molécula esto es muy
importante porque es lo que le da al
agua a sus propiedades tan especiales
ahora algo que tenemos que tomar en
cuenta es que en química dibujamos estos
electrones y estos enlaces muy limpios y
ordenados pero en realidad no es así los
electrones están brincando
constantemente de hecho si buscamos los
electrones esto es más como una
probabilidad en donde podríamos
encontrarlos entonces en lugar de ver
estos electrones solo aquí y los enlaces
siempre así en realidad es más como una
nube alrededor de los diferentes átomos
esto es solo una probabilidad de en
dónde podemos encontrar los electrones
mientras están brincando y moviéndose
ahora lo más interesante sobre el agua
es que el oxígeno es extremadamente
electro negativo el oxígeno que es
este oxígeno es muy electro negativo es
uno de los elementos más electro
negativos que conocemos y claro es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno pero a
qué me refiero con electro negativo
bueno electro negativo es solo una forma
de decir que acapara electrones acá para
electrones
al oxígeno le gusta tener los electrones
más cerca de él que de sus compañeros a
los que está unido entonces aun en estos
enlaces covalentes podemos decir oye se
supone que debemos compartir los
electrones y el oxígeno dice bueno yo
quiero que estén más tiempo conmigo así
que los electrones pasan más tiempo
cerca del oxígeno que de los hidrógenos
y ya se imaginarán qué pasa aquí se
forma una carga parcial negativa esta es
una letra griega delta y simboliza una
carga parcial en este caso es una carga
parcial negativa porque recuerden que
los electrones son negativos pero como
acá tenemos una pequeña falta de
electrones porque los electrones pasan
más tiempo cerca del oxígeno aquí se
forma una carga parcial positiva y por
acá también y bueno cuando observamos
una molécula de agua no parece muy
interesante pero se vuelve interesante
observamos varias moléculas de agua
interactuando entre ellas voy a dibujar
otra molécula tenemos un oxígeno y dos
hidrógenos y tenemos dos enlaces también
tenemos una carga parcial negativa y por
acá tenemos una carga parcial positiva
entonces imaginemos que el lado que
tiene la carga parcial negativa es
atraída al lado que tiene una carga
parcial positiva esa atracción se conoce
como puente de hidrógeno este es un
puente de hidrógeno puente
de hidrógeno y esta es la clave para el
comportamiento del agua más adelante
veremos todas las formas en las que los
puentes de hidrógeno le dan al agua sus
características únicas los puentes de
hidrógeno son más débiles que los
enlaces covalentes pero son lo
suficientemente fuertes para que el agua
tenga esa naturaleza fluida que
conocemos a temperaturas y presiones
normales esa naturaleza permite que
estas moléculas se atraigan y tengan
cohesión pero también se pueden separar
y seguir fluyendo imaginemos que aquí se
forma otro puente de hidrógeno con otra
molécula de agua vamos a poner los
hidrógenos carga parcial negativa y
carga parcial positiva en los siguientes
vídeos veremos que los puentes de
hidrógeno son la clave para todas las
propiedades del agua como por ejemplo su
comportamiento al calentarla para
regular la temperatura también
la razón por la que los lagos no se
congelan completamente incluso es la
clave de algunas de las propiedades que
tienen que ver con el enfriamiento
evaporativo y tensión superficial así
como adhesión y cohesión pero bueno si
pensamos en los sistemas biológicos esa
polaridad que tenemos en las moléculas
de agua y los puentes de hidrógeno son
la clave para que el agua pueda actuar
como un solvente es decir que moléculas
polares se puedan disolver en el agua
veremos más sobre esto en los siguientes
vídeos